[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'édition
publique ce lundi 9 mai 2022 bien sûr
investiture commémoration poutine
ukraine et europe ce sont les quelques
mots qu'on a le plus entendu ces trois
derniers jours on va en parler avec
notre invité aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
à strasbourg a fait des propositions
importantes ou pas pour l'avenir de
l'europe poutine a célébré la victoire
de 1945 sur fond de guerre en ukraine et
sur le plan national samedi cérémonie
d'investiture des manuels macron
quelques heures plus tard âge heures
hasard du calendrier ou pas et bien
meeting d'investiture des candidats de
gauche réunis sous la bannière de l'efi
rebaptisé nuque sponsors alexis corbière
merci d'être avec nous pardon de vous
lever le nez de votre feuille vous êtes
bienvenu dans audition publique la
bataille des législatives est lancé mais
comment prétendre mener une majorité
parlementaire sans être élu soi même
jean luc mélenchon vraiment n'ira pas ce
sera la question qu'on vous posera tout
à l'heure en attendant un accord
historique a été conclue à gauche il ya
aussi des dissidences des critiques êtes
vous prêt à discuter avec ceux qui
contestent vos choix alors qu'ils
appartiennent à nuxe sur le papier la
question vous sera posée tout à l'heure
entre autres par sophie de ravinel avant
cela brigitte boucher thème traduit des
chaînes parlementaires reviendront sur
le programme d'union et juste avant
vincent roux mettra son grain de sel
vous verrez mais d'abord quelques
instants ensemble alexis cambiaire
mêlant fou premier ministre tout le
monde a salué l'habileté du slogan pour
mobiliser son camp ça n'est qu'un slogan
est-ce que ça n'est qu'un slogan
finalement mobilisateur ou est-ce que ça
y est vrai bien qu'on puisse être
premier ministre oui je crois faut
toujours d'abord de manière générale se
battre pour cherchant d'être majoritaire
sur ces idées
deuxièmement on pourrait me répondre
monsieur car bien vous n'êtes pas
raisonnable les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pourtant regardons l'analyse que
nous tirons du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle car enfin il a
peu de temps les français viennent de
voter on peut déjà utilisés quand une
photographie si je puis dire de quelque
chose d'intéressant il y a trois blocs
monsieur macron est en tête puis vient
le rassemblement national et nous sommes
là à 410 mille voit ça nulle ce chiffre
devient célèbre mais à partir de là
trois blocs qui sont quand même de
taille peu ou prou équivalente même si
je vous accorde que nous sommes en
troisième position et donc éliminé bon
alors
c'est la 5ème jeu marine nos
raisonnements pardon oui mais marine le
pen ne vous a pas raté ce week-end elle
a fait son retour absolument absolument
elle a fait son retour après une pause
post présidentielle elle a bien insisté
sur le fait que jean luc mélenchon
premier ministre première opposants je
la cite ça a fait rire tout le monde
jean luc mélenchon a fait élire emmanuel
macron fin de citation alors je reprends
mon raisonnement à partir de là nous
pensons nous que sur notamment à la
lumière de ce qui s'est passé en 2010
est que parfois il ya un électorat qui
se démobilisent car il ne voit plus
d'enjeu en raison de la perception qu'il
a la 5ème république que la seule chose
importante c'est le président et se
démobilisent nous voulons qu'il reste
mobilisé et ne peut rester mobilisés que
sur un objectif de victoire pour changer
la vie vraiment concrètement pour
augmenter le smic pour but de faire le
blocage des prix dont on va parler pour
défendre les services publics etc etc et
ça c'est possible si nous restons non
seulement les 7,7 millions de voix
rassembler autour de jean luc mélenchon
si nous restons longtemps possible
mobiliser encore et si en plus nous
élargissons de deux manières j'ai envie
de dire d'abord en n'oubliant jamais que
beaucoup de des millions de français ne
sont ne sont pas allés voter au premier
tour les abstentionnistes pour leur
parler ils sont souvent sociologiquement
des gens que j'ai l'ambition de
représenter plutôt des gens de milieux
modestes et deuxièmement aussi nous
élargissons à d'autres forces politiques
l'afer est bien mené avouez le depuis
cela semblait impossible et on va nous
sommes rassemblés dans une nouvelle
union populaire et nous parlons à tout
le pays pour dire cet électron a été élu
surtout par une défaite de m le pen et
on peut maintenant un ratio vernement
qui mène une politique sociale
écologique et plus démocratique
permettez moi de rappeler députés de
cette année vous êtes candidat à nouveau
avant de faire réélection de jean luc
mélenchon qui dit qu emmanuel macron n'a
pas de mandat alors il a emprunté
rendons à césar ce qui est à servir à
viviez force que tablier fort mais c'est
vrai que finalement olivier faure avait
raison de rappeler que hormis qu'est ce
qu'il a dit de fort durant cette
élection présidentielle qu'il fallait
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans que le rsa
devait être conditionnés et puis après à
vous et vous qui êtes une fine
observatrice de la situation qu'on avait
du mal à voir exactement quelles étaient
ses grandes idées alors peut-être en
parlant de l'europe sur la réforme
institutionnelle sur la transition
écologique souvent emmanuel macron est
un homme qui a le verbe en flammes et
puis finalement quand on gratte un peu
si je puis dire on ne voit pas très bien
concrètement ce qu'ils proposent et
hormis cela regardons ensemble si vous
voulez on peut reprendre qu'est ce que
veut faire emmanuel macron pour les cinq
ans qui viennent vous aurez du mal mais
non mais ça parle du principe de dire ce
sera emmanuel macron n'a pas de mandat
c'est une lapalissade de dire que
effectivement il aura ou non une
majorité après les élections il estime
en attendant
il a un mandat pour l'instant dit-il un
programme et il n'a pas l'intention de
mettre en oeuvre son programme
d'après ce qu'on a compris avant la fin
des élections législatives qu'est ce
qu'ont voulu contester sa légitimité
alors vous êtes en train de dire autre
chose premièrement n'ont jamais semblé
aussi faut-il le répéter que la manu
emmanuel macron et président de la
république dont il n'a pas contesté il
ya dire il n'est pas présent la
république je ne suis pas de donald
trump qui vais dire à mes partisans
d'aller chez de faire tu sais trop
quelle folie antidémocratique spasad
sujet maintenant notre nos institutions
sont telles qu à l'élection du président
de la république dont avons le et
notamment pour des raisons qui sont
aussi compréhensible la crise en ukraine
etc on a un président qui s'est déclaré
au dernier moment qu'il n'a fait qu'un
seul meeting c'est de l'inédit qui a
fait très peu d'émissions qui a même
refusé de débattre avec ses concurrents
qui a fait un programme assez léger ces
aidants et donc comme le dit olivier
faure je reprends ses mots le mandat est
extrêmement ténus et j'affirme ici que
s'il fait 27% si je me trompe vous me
corrigez au premier tour il
essentiellement élu au second tour dans
un roger de madame le pen alors à partir
de l'arrêt conditions plaisir que votre
corps il est en partie alimentée par
ceux qui voulaient aussi faire obstacle
un marine le pen au deuxième tour comme
vous aviez appelé les électeurs à le
faire donc on est toujours élu par une
partie des entiers de l'autre
premièrement nous nous allons aux
élections légistatives président pour
pour cesser la polémique entre nous il
ya traversa le débat intellectuel c'est
intéressant
donc comment trancher ce que je suis en
train de dire que finalement tout ça est
assez fou quand même vous renvoyer la
pareille et pourquoi pas les élections
législatives sont la formule 1 nous
avons un programme et vous essayez
l'ignorance en doute et bien voyons dans
cette élection qui est important pas
seulement je n'ai pas seulement dans le
temple de la vie parlementaire oui les
élections législatives sont importantes
et on peut enfin parlementariste et si
vous permettez l'expression
nos institutions en notant que du
pouvoir à ce président de la république
omniscient cette espèce de monarchie
présidentielle comme je le dis parfois
pour piquer un peu et faire en sorte que
ce soit à l'assemblée que le pouvoir sur
ton formidable lcp devrait applaudir et
devrait le priait de la chaîne lcp c'est
un mélenchon qui monte parce que c'est
nul qui dit c'est aux députés de décider
ce que doit être la politique alors on
va passer du parlement national que vous
évoquez nous sommes heureux de
représenter ici au parlement européen à
strasbourg emmanuel macron s'est adressé
tout à leur parlement européen ont donc
on verra tout à l'heure à ce qu'il a dit
sur les
effectivement les institutions ce très
intéressant mais déjà un point il
propose une structure européenne qui
s'appelle la communauté politique pour
accueillir le cren candidate à entrer
dans l'union européenne plus rapidement
est-ce que c'est intéressant ce serait
une structure qui finalement permettre à
des pays qui partagent les valeurs de
l'europe devenir sans passer par le
tamis extrêmement laborieux élan d'une
d'une vraie adhésion à l'europe vous
êtes-vous dit oui c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'ukraine un peu une usine
à gaz concernant mais moi je suis du
côté du peuple ukrainien faut défendre
l'ukraine indiscutable quel que soit
fait dire on va pas conditionner sa
l'adhésion à l'union européenne je ne
vois pas moi je ne suis pas favorable
mais comme de manière générale un
élargissement de l'union européenne à
des pays bien souvent vous savez le
problème de la tendance en ukraine à
deux choses nous devons défendre
l'ukraine en position sur le terrain
diplomatique
agir pour accueillir ceux qui sont
contraints de quitter ce pays faire tout
ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour que
poutine retire ses troupes qu'il soit
sanctionné notamment son entourage est
lui-même et ses accès on pourrait
dérouler là dessus pour autant après la
discussion qui consiste à dire est-ce
que tel ou tel pays doit rejoindre
l'union européenne participer à ce
marché européen souvent ce qui a été
fait ces dernières années c'est que des
pays qui sont rentrés et pourtant je
suis comme on dirait
dans une réponse à ma question est ce
que vous êtes favorables à ce qu'il ya
une comité communauté politique qui
permette à l'ukraine mais ça nous le
savons mais pourquoi pourquoi olivier
magne la mère de s'arrimer alors j'étais
en train de bronzer pourquoi pour faire
quoi pour partager les valeurs pour
appartenir à cette famille est
progressivement
saddam prochaine la ds que mais pour
faire quoi est-ce qu'on peut être
politique est rentré dans le détail pour
faire quoi à quoi ça sert qu'est ce que
ça veut dire les valeurs est-ce que nous
faisons rentrer des pays dans lequel le
salaire minimum existe qu'elle n'y a pas
droit social
non il y en a pas
la libre concurrence mission on a fait
entrer dernièrement des pays dans lequel
on leur a dit votre valeur ajoutée va
être que vous êtes moins disant social
moins disant fiscal on a délocalisé des
entreprises dans des pays comme le note
pour aller là bas non pas au nom des
valeurs au nom du fait que les salariés
étaient moins payés les conditions
d'adhésion direct vous êtes contre
d'autres questions des ménages est en
train de vous dire moi je ne je ne suis
pas à mon goût go qui accueille qu'elle
consiste à dire les valeurs de l'europe
je ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'elles sont
du moins je sais aujourd'hui
concrètement des traités de libre
échange qui disent que la concurrence
doit être libre et non faussée la des
services publics sont par exemple
je le souhaite mais que je le fais
monsieur urban prendre en hongrie ne me
remplit pas de joie ce qui se passe en
pologne où des droits fondamentaux sont
remis en cause on peut en parler et puis
compris vous savez la démocratie
aujourd'hui l'attention de l'europe avec
ses pas six ans ben je sais pas c'est ce
que vous vouliez faire vous en parler
tout avec brigitte et est amené
livraisons d'armes juste un mot encore
avant de de les accueillir les
livraisons d'armes monte en intensité et
poutine dit que ceux qui livrent des
armes se mettre dans la situation d'être
déco belligérants est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec non mais poutine doit
baisser d'un ton prudent ne va pas avoir
ce vocabulaire accepté ce vocabulaire de
menaces de toute manière est ce que fait
pour ça
il sent bon nombre de témoignages qui
remontent montre qui la manifestion des
choses qui sont de l'or des crimes de
son livre des armes et elles sont de
plus en plus nombreuses et on le voit sa
des résultats sur le terrain est ce que
ces livreurs d'armes
nous ce que nous avons dit depuis le
début c'est que l'on ne souhaite pas
qu'il y ait des cherry et on traîne la
france dans une guerre où toute l'armée
française s'engagerait là dedans
d'accord donc à partir de là ni vous ni
moi n'avons les éléments pour juger quel
type d'armes quel type de matériel il
faut livrer maintenant mais parce que
c'est une question avait déplu d'art de
gazelle silence du tout il s'agit
d'aider
comment ce qui a été fait alors c'est
vrai vous êtes à la commission de la
défense a déjà parlé et comme on irait
gillman à cui si je puis dire d'avoir
répété quelque chose qui était déjà dans
la presse donc au bout d'un moment où
comment dirais-je je vais pas faire le
plus faim parce que nombre de gens qui
osent américains par exemple qui sont
les plus gros livreur d'armes où ils le
font de façon massive et grâce à cela la
résistance et craignait à des résultats
sur le terrain ça vous gêne non j'ai pas
dit que ça me gênait je dis seulement
que je ne veux pas que la france engagé
dans un conflit ouvert dans ce quelque
chose qui peut être de dimension
mondiale tout ce que sir le terrain peut
aider concrètement à aider le peuple
ukrainien pourquoi pas après je n'ai pas
les éléments pour
justement parlons-en moi je ne suis pas
stratégie militaire je ne sais pas c'est
qui il voit que les états unis mais
murray a envoyé des dix hommes sur place
j'ai lu dans la presse comme vous que
certaines opérations qui ont détruit des
chars russes été menée directement par
des gens qui étaient entraînées par
l'armée américaine je ne sais pas tout
ça est ce que vous y avoir c'est que si
je puis me permettre sur le terrain il
ya des choses qui doivent avoir lieu
mais ne perdons pas le caractère aussi
diplomatique qui doit être mené des
petits résultant lieu qui commence à
être intéressant mais je crois qu'il
faut les en consigne de monsieur poutine
tous ces oligarques dont on a beaucoup
parlé
de sanctionner et je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut continuer maintenant
ça commence à avancer et ceux dont on a
ce qu'on s'aperçoit par temps de parler
sur un ton de mitraillette mais c'est
important ce dont on s'aperçoit parfois
c'est que quand on exercer des pressions
économiques notamment sur ses célèbres
désormais oligarques russes c'est que
nous n'avons pas les moyens parce que
cette europe dont vous avez parlé nous
ne donne pas les moyens de savoir qui
appartient à quoi et tous ces montages
financiers vous masser à la fraude et
l'évasion fiscales sont terry parce que
ça nous impuissante j'en appelle enfants
parlaient de ses regrets que l'union
européenne ait décidé de fournir des
armes à l'ukraine il l'avait dit il ne
l'a pas dit comme ça si vous l'avez
écouté dernièrement il a dit que les
moyens on l'étalé
changez d'entre nous pourtant je
regrette que l'union européenne ait
décidé de fournir des environs guerre
cette décision forêts de nos d'écologie
oui nous je ne souhaite pas que la
france s'engage dans un conflit ouvert
face à la russie d'accord en
deuxièmement ce qu'a dit jean luc
mélenchon aussi c'est que à l'heure
actuelle le seul qui avait vraiment les
éléments pour juger de ce qu'il fallait
envoyer ou pas c'est emmanuel macron je
ne fais pas partie de la war room
aujourd'hui qui ce qui se déroule et
j'invite chacun à ne pas faire les
stratèges en chambre voilà c'est tout ce
que je dis donc il ya des choses peuvent
être qu'ils peuvent être faites mais je
me méfie de paroles qui sont exagérées
d'un côté ou de l'autre ce qu'il nous
faut rien faire ce qui est pas mon cas
où ceux qui cassent menons en un
claquement en un clin d'oeil nous
engagerait dans un conflit de dimension
mondiale et nucléaire donc pour trouver
le ton juste de ce point de vue là au
mois de juin ce qui gèle en chemin et
premier ministre nous serons fidèles et
ratera la solidarité avec le peuple
pardon
poser des questions mais les actes de
solidarité non mais demander pardon on
va d'abord remporté les élections
légistatives vous avez une réponse
n'est pas allé à ce stade me dire
qu'il y ait des gestes de solidarité à
apporter
20 cents ou aidant un instant brigitte
et etam ne rejoigne mais d'abord vincent
au bon soir vincent grâce à vous chère
épouse
avec votre question directe du figaro
live on vous écoute toujours l'ukraine
d'ailleurs et c'était exactement donc
c'est pas complètement une pause bonsoir
avec 6 corbières
la question justement aux membres de
l'agression défense que vous êtes c'est
vous n'êtes pas dans l'art war room mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
déclaration du pape françois qui a
déclaré que l'attitude de poutine a pu
être je cite facilité fermez les
guillemets part je cite encore les
aboiements de l'otan à la porte de la
russie fermez les guillemets est ce que
c'est les propos de stratèges en chambre
je me permettrais pas de dire ça de
manière générale à une autorité
religieuse et en particulier à ce pape
qui s'assure prendra peut-être je trouve
dit parfois sur des grands sujets comme
la pauvreté des paroles qui détonne et
de mon point de vue dans le bon sens
alors il ya des tonnes dans le bon sens
ben comment dirais-je alors où le peuple
ukrainien subi ce qui est en train
d'avoir lieu je ne veux pas donner
l'impression
je rembobine le film pour se dire à
l'heure actuelle il ya un responsable
s'appelle vladimir poutine il ya un
homme qui se comporte de manière
terrible et les conséquences humaines
sur le terrain sont insupportables après
comment dirais-je les historiens
peut-être nous aiderons et puis même je
parle surtout politique c'est ça qui est
intéressant de voir comment est
peut-être depuis 10 20 ans notamment en
raison de cet otan qui réduit
disparaître me semble-t-il au lendemain
de la chute du mur de berlin de la place
dont les états unis la manière dont les
états unis l'ont utilisée pour faire de
nouvelles alliances avec de nouveaux
objectifs ça n'a pas calmé la situation
d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi ça a été
reproché à jean luc lampions qui depuis
longtemps dit notamment l'installation
de bases militaires en pologne de base
de missiles qui pouvait frapper le
territoire us étaient des éléments de
tension en aurait d'ailleurs c'était ce
que j'exprime à la position de me
semble-t-il traditionnelle de la france
qui même quand françois hollande était
président de la république était plutôt
défavorable à cette extension de l'otan
donc de ce point de vue là ce que dit le
pape françois je découvre sa citation
par dont me semble plutôt intéressant il
a il n'a pas tort mais pardon
s'était déclarée déclaration à l'
interview au corriere della serra
écoutez c'est une belle une déclaration
ourbise et orbi mais qui permet d'avoir
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
je je je la prends mais je trouve que
c'est une parole forte et que je me
reconnais qu'à nantes là dedans je dois
dire eh ben voilà ça c'est un scoop
merci vincent a posé la question
je crois c'est personnel bonne soirée à
vous vincent en face
bonsoir alexis corbière alors pourquoi
jean luc mélenchon ne se présente il pas
aux élections législatives écoutez c'est
une décision personnelle et moi je suis
un ami jean-luc depuis le grand seigneur
il a dit je ne dis pas que ce qu'il a
dit vraisemblablement pas alors je vais
vous dire tout à l'heure je n'ai encore
eu au téléphone en lui disant mais est
ce que tu es sûr voilà il a l'air assez
déterminé est claire là dessus mais
c'est d'y aller ne pas se présenter y
considère bon déjà c'est un homme qui
même s'il est en pleine forme mais qui a
une longue vie militants derrière lui
qui a déjà été parlementaire qui sait ce
que ça signifie travail de parlementaire
mais je crois qu'il a il a donné si je
peux paraître expression il pense qu'il
peut être utile
déjà en étant celui qui conduit cette
campagne législative
il est un peu fatigué non c'est parce
que je sais que j'y pense qu'il peut
être justement au rôle qui est le sien
aujourd'hui d'abord utile à conduire la
campagne législative et j'espère que je
ne ferais pas souvent mais nous pensons
gagner une bâton pour gagner est d'abord
l'objectif de jean luc mélenchon c'est
de créer des conditions soit premier
ministre d'accord donc c'est ça
l'objectif
et en plus il a eu ce n'est pas
seulement une taquiner il l'a dit à la
tribune le fait qu'il soit candidat nul
parfait qui pourra pleinement être
invité par vous vous coller et c'est
sans qu'immédiatement tous ceux qui sont
dans sa circonscription soit obligé
d'être invitée ce qui est la règle mais
plus fondamentalement il est possible il
est possible d'être premier ministre
sans être parlementaire monsieur kresa
ex en est la démonstration vivant
d'accord mais en cas de cohabitation
généralement le premier ministre c'est
le député chef de file de l'opposition
ça serait une cohabitation là c'est le
cas de les deux cohabitations qu'on a
connus sous la vème république que
c'était lionel jospin ou chirac non mais
attendez widor balladur cesser pour que
les gens comprennent tout quoi il s'agit
si la majorité n'est pas favorable à
manuel macro donc il est obligé de
nommer quelqu'un qui se retrouvent
soutenu par la majorité de l'assemblée
nationale si donc ces nounous nous avons
dit dans le cadre de l'alliance que
celui que nous soutiendrons il s'appelle
jean luc mélenchon dans deux choses
l'une soit emmanuel macron est un
démocrate je pense qu'il l'est il dit
dont acte mais mes amis ont été battus
il ya une nouvelle majorité qui a écrit
noir sur blanc et qu'il a même mis sur
les affiches celui que nous voulons être
prémunie s'appelle jean luc mélenchon
peut il doit respecter cela il ya pas
obligé
mais pourquoi des coupures utiles
d'autres allant pour que leur maison ne
respecterait pas s'en prenait bien que
c'est la question du principe
effectivement que le leader de la
majorité élue en cas de cohabitation est
lui-même un élu voilà c'était une
tradition
comment dirais-je ça normal et c'est
surtout le président qui choisit le
premier ministre même si c'est
l'opposition qui était oui mais le
président le choisi cette année de fait
ceux qui reçoivent cette chaîne sont peu
féru des questions est jeune mais il
choisit en fonction de la majorité quel
est l'intérêt de nommer quelqu'un qui
soit élu
pourra contester un contexte vous l'avez
commenté nous sommes réunis avec des
partis nous ont tous mis dans nos
déclarations communes que en cas de
malades voire d'autres preuves celui que
nous présenterons oppose deux prévenus
s'étaient rendus à berlin emmanuel
macron a dit qu'il avait en tête son
premier ministre vous pensez qu'ils
pensent à jean luc mélenchon
alors en cas d'échec c'est pourquoi ces
chariots bas je ne sais pas en cas
d'échec pour lui est ce que ce serait la
fin d'un destin national pour jean luc
mélenchon
je dirais que le personnage est
tellement un homme de combat de combat
intellectuel et c'est que jean lui je
pense jusqu'au bout jusqu'à son dernier
souffle continuera à écrire des livres
faire des conférences
un
acteur de la vie politique mais un
acteur politique question qui anime le
débat politique et voilà donc candidat
mais moi c'est pas mon rôle en plus j'ai
bien compris que son propos est de
considérer que si tu ne gagnes pas là il
va participer à ce que la force qu'il a
construit quand tu es mais
moi je non mais vous puisque vous et
votre ami un
ami j'espère que ceux qui nous regardent
autour pas que c'est la langue de bois
c'est à lui de le deviens moi je veux
pas parler en son nom c'est à lui de
l'ue dian il a il a joué en rôle
suffisamment important non seulement ça
a été mon ami mais ça a été mon maître
en politique quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup
inspiré qui m'a aidé et cetera qui m'a
beaucoup influencé dans mon engagement
moi comme beaucoup d'autres et je pense
qu'il a ce statut particulier où c'est
aussi à lui un peu de nous dire comment
ils voient les choses par la suite puis
on verra si ça correspond à nos attentes
a ajouté j'ai parlé ont à dire
mais il est pas un premier ministre
qu'est ce qui ferait pendant cinq ans
abbas je prends la voir 10 l iphone mon
écrire des livres est ce que c'est
d'abord un rôle intellectuel qui va
jouer à eelv à cette aune hommes des
cris je crois que la manière dont il a
pris goût je le sais non seulement
meeting à des conférences notamment dans
des universités a parlé à la jeunesse à
être un théoricien du nouveau mouvement
dans lequel nous sommes la crise
écologique qui est là la crise sociale
ce qu'il a expliqué déjà dans beaucoup
d'ouvragés je pense qu'il aura bouclé
redevance est ce qui pourrait être le
leader de la nuque plat la nouvelle
union populaire écologiste est
écologique et sociale comme il est le
leader de l efi aujourd'hui par exemple
je crois là encore sans avoir énormément
discuté avec lui là dessus qu'il se
décalera un petit peu par rapport à ça
ce sera pas lui le secrétaire général du
mouvement romantique quand même pardon
un rôle moins actif dans les cinq
chaînes moi je laisse dire se sont
échangé avec lui de ce qu'il a envie de
faire c'est plutôt un apport d'abord
intellectuelle
mais si j'ai dit non
mais ceci dit puisque je vous ai livré
tout à l'heure la discussion que j'ai
eue avec lui et que les genoux nous on
n'est pas en train de jouer jean luc est
très toutes les conditions et sorties
exalté en plus afin d'exalter
enthousiasmé par ce que nous avons fait
samedi en disant les c'est jouable donc
là il est tout on est troublé parce que
c'est premier ministre aurait une
certaine façon premier ministre ou un
retrait relative avec un rôle
intellectuel bon alors on a quand même
qui doutent de la réussite de votre
entreprise parmi lesquels françois
hollande qui prédit déjà un échec à
cette alliance 1 ce matin il a dit cela
ne permettra pas la victoire votre
réaction
aucune je ne sais pas mais je dis rien
n'est fait ni chaud ni froid c'est
peut-être les commercialisant la
république je toujours membre du parti
socialiste je confie dans les nippes je
vais vous dire une chose il ya quelques
jours je suis j'ai eu des propos
qui se voulait drôle après bernard
casoni avec ce
talent là je parle je veux dire c'est
que je vais arrêter de faire des blagues
vous aider en fait
[Musique]
je tiens à dire que je réagissais
c'était votre confrère laurence ferrari
qui lisait une déclaration monsieur
cazals qui est extrêmement dur voire
même méprisante vis-à-vis
des gens comme moi je suis attaché à la
république à la laïcité et je trouve
qu'on ne joue pas avec ces thèmes et me
voir traiter de quelqu'un qui
mépriserait la république et la laïcité
j'ai trouvé ça un peu dur donc j'ai
répondu en disant puisque on était les
jours lors parlante que le départ
monsieur cazals etc etc depuis jeanne
tirer la conclusion là c'est françois
hollande que franchement j'ai pas envie
de passer mon temps à commenter voilà je
trouve même mais après je suis triste
que même s'ils le pensent ils pourraient
faire silence et ne pas gêner ceux qui
dans son parti ont continué à défendre
le parti socialiste et cherche
aujourd'hui après en avoir discuté
démocratiquement et adopté
démocratiquement une orientation cherche
à mettre en place quelque chose
d'éphémère françois hollande oui c'est
un tireur dans le dos à l'heure actuelle
quelque on a l'impression qu'elle ne
propose rien d'autre que de passer son
temps à vouloir que nous échouons latino
de olivier faur parce que ce sont des
lâches les enquêteurs dans le dos non
mais vous avez qu attendez vous
l'expression voyez-vous l'est si je veux
dire c'est qu'il est en train alors que
son parti a discuté à adopter une
orientation monsieur hollande n'a rien
d'autre à dire que ça va échouer ça va
échouer ça va échouer en gros on a
l'impression qu'ils ça fait le jeu je ne
sais pas si c'est un objectif de
emmanuel macron machine qui garde quand
même sa carte au parti socialiste vient
de rentrer de l'union ça vous dérange
pas que vous l'accueille à bras ouverts
ya pas de croire pourtant répété moi
j'ai pas entendu il garde sa carte au
parti socialiste dont parlait de
françois hollande mais je suis pas
comme un hacker des bons
de josé bové daniel cohn-bendit par
exemple ancien député européen il estime
que cet accord est une escroquerie
dictée seulement par des tractations
électorale est ce que ça vous étonne est
ce que ça vous déçoit je vous en veux de
passer du temps là tu franchement
j'étais jeune mais parce que je trouve
que c'est incroyable non mais je vais
vous dire une chose non mais c'est pas
des réactions
non ce n'est pas vrai je vais vous dire
il est un fait et je crois que votre
rôle mais ça ça n'est pas de chercher
qui n'est pas d'accord parce que c'est
pas ce qu'on doit faire ce qu'on doit
dire
je viens et j'accepte nous ils
m'attendent et je vous dis pas mais je
pouvais avoir une opinion comme
dirigeant politique que de vous dire par
exemple qu'à l'heure où il ya 1500
candidats qui se sont retirés ans
l'attend cet accord qui sur les réseaux
on dit généralement qu'il le faisait
avec enthousiasme que je vois bien que
l'on traque à quel endroit il y aura un
petit problème et la voix discordantes
jeudi qu'au bout d'un moment c'est
vouloir faire croire qu'il y aura une
levée de boucliers contre cet accord
alors que globalement la grande famille
de la gauche écologique est heureuse de
cet accord alors il ya peut-être ici ou
là pour des raisons de françois hollande
qui peut il a subi un échec il a du mal
que ça réussisse vous connaissez ça
quand on échoue parfois on n'a pas envie
que les autres réussissent à l'origine
des membres a
échoué bernard cazeneuve a quitté le
parti socialiste stéphane le foll est
contre
finalement vous avez la peau du ps non
mais c'est pas ça l'objectif non je
crois qu'on contraire olivier faur bar
faire revivre le parti socialiste idéal
jeudi 2001 jean luc mélenchon avait dit
je veux remplacer le ps fait c'est ça
non mais remplacé d'être la grande force
politique qui crée les conditions du
changement la ville et va donc affaiblir
considérablement le pâtisson m est le
remplacer un objet utilisé oui être la
grande force qui a occupé le parti
socialiste qui était celui qui était le
parti qui a changé la vie en 1981 nous
souhaitons jouer ce rôle là aussi mais
le fer avec dote la même façon que le
gardien socialiste ps mais pour le
remplacer à la même façon que le génie
d'un homme comme françois mitterrand
quand il est dans l'opposition c'est qui
va faire va passer de l'ail sefyu lui à
prendre la direction du parti suisse et
crée des conditions de l'union de la
gauche dans des conditions encore plus
difficiles notamment en raison de ce
qu'était le parti communiste à l'époque
l'existence d'une on se dit tout ce que
vous voulez ce que je vais vous raconter
la hague rentrée c'est que notre tâche
est de reprendre 7 h à la salle à deux
pas du tout la même histoire et pourquoi
c'est pas loin juste parce que ces
derniers le programme de jean luc
mélenchon mais pourquoi vous dites ça ça
c'est la retraite à 60 ans
mais la rotation sont on sait pas le
programme de fabien roussel c'est pas le
programme d'europe écologie
dans une alliance à 4 le parti
socialiste qui n'est pas défavorable à
la retraite à 60 ans mais effectivement
dans le cadre de ces parce qu'il n'ya
pas que le parti si demain tu es toute
l'affection des gens mais que j'ai pour
ce parti d'accord c'est ni une alliance
et nous faisons ensemble un parti
quelque chose de programmatique et enfin
puisque on s'amuse à faire de l'histoire
tout de même quand on est socialiste
on est pour la retraite à 60 ans ça
n'est pas contraire à l'histoire du
parti socialiste n'est pas contraire à
l'essence hoymille terreur
dans les 110 propositions du candidat
mitterrand il vient la retraite à 60 ans
l année mais en quel est donc le sait
rien c'est horrible affaire
est déjà très critique fin avril disait
ça va coûter 60 du genre à voile et on
les a convaincus manifestons la force de
l'onu ce qui est sortie des urnes a
réussi à convaincre les derniers doutes
sur le fait que c'était possible et
nécessaire d'ailleurs parce que c'est ça
qui est important et j'ai répondu et
pardon parfois du style un peu un peu
vif à laquelle je vous réponds mais
fondamentalement lave on est dans le
vrai sujet je ne sais pas si nous
gagnons au mois de juin mais je ne veux
pas la retraite à 65 ans des matches je
veux la retraite à 60 ans parce que
c'est nécessaire parce qu'une faire
sentir
déjà
dans une situation de malaise
on est toujours sur la règle des 40
annuités celle qui était prévue dans le
programme de jean luc mélenchon mais on
l'a pas vu dans votre dernier communiqué
avant le dernier communiqué commun avec
le parti socialiste est un droit à la
retraite à 60 ans avec une attention
particulière pour les carrières longues
discontinue les métiers pénibles mais
les 40 annuités on sait pas où elles
sont à ce stade on vous l'a dit mais je
le répète avec plaisir quarante annuités
alors on me dit mais aujourd'hui quand
on commence à travailler à 23 ans
amènera ce que donc on a 40 annuités à
63 73 ans voilà certes mais alors à
l'heure actuelle si vous partez que vous
n'avez pas la totalité de vos annuités
non seulement vous avez un effet de du
manque des deux trois années puisqu'ils
sont parle de 63 par rapport à 60
j'espère qu'on me suis non plus que
j'avais la décote vous avez une double
sanction nous on va supprimer la décote
bien de sa sanction pardon donc on aura
ta dire que lio sera éventuellement
temps des sites avec 97% de votre aide
de vos de vous de vos annuités si vous
en avez je commence à 13 25 ans et
cauchemars à 60 ans je n'aurai pas
d'école à l'heure actuelle aurait pas
marrant
on n'aurait pas tout à fait si on dit la
baisse des prix mais aujourd'hui ce qui
y est
vous dit le sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui coûte le plus cher c'est la
décote quand vous n'avez pas la totalité
des cotisations partait avec 40 annuités
à 63 ans et si vous partez à 60 ans vous
aurrez aurre délabré de retrait par
rapport à un finissant meilleur que le
système actuel bon sens dont on parle
est ce que c'est mais on part plus tôt
mais en a moins d'argent falla y ait une
baisse des pensions c'est aujourd'hui il
laisse des pensions madame est ce que
vous savez je vous va mais coupat
parlent quand je les dis une personne
sur deux aujourd'hui qu'à plus de 60 ans
et soit en invalidité soient au chômage
les gens n'arrivent pas avec la totalité
de leur trimestre mais a envoyé
musiciens qui part il est entre amis la
soixante trois ans et demi et non
seulement ils n'arrivent pas à bout post
c'est vrai parce que parce qu'ils sont
licenciés mer donc aujourd'hui on est on
est on est à 43,5 leurrons pas si je dis
pas de sottises donc non seulement le
nombre de cotisations et à 43,5 en plus
à une décote terrible qui fait baisser
les pensions et de toute manière donc de
tout quand bien même évidemment si vous
n'avez pas cotisé 40 ans je répète que
vous avez 95 % de vos trimestre vous
avez 95 % ça dépend aussi après sur le
calcul des thèmes des meilleures années
que nous allons prendre mais en plus
vous subissez la décote alors je sais
pas si cette technique pour ceux qui
nous écoutent mais ça amène des
situations terme et du moment mais il ya
quand même une baisse de pan exactement
comme
des pensionnaires mais demain aussi non
mais si on fait passer quarantaine et
aujourd'hui elle est terrible mais je
comprends que tu en es j'aimerais comme
notre propos c'est que mélenchon et son
programme celui de la nouvelle union
populaire améliore la condition de
retraite des gens parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est terrible aujourd'hui faut cotiser
très longtemps vous semblez quand je
vous dis ça ça me semble faire ni chaud
ni froid
jusqu'à la totalité donc qui ne
travaillent pas ce qui arrive pas
laisser les carrières longues et la
pénibilité soit prise les sens puissent
partir à 60 ans certes mais si on part
avec 40 annuités à 63 ans aujourd'hui
enfin en demain on sera mieux payés que
si on part à 60 ans aujourd'hui et
demain sera mieux payés que si on part à
60 ans serait dans votre projet savait
très bien qu'en baisse des pensions si
on veut passer quarante annuités non je
dis qu'actuellement il ya une baisse des
pauvres et une décote il y en aura une
comme me comprendront pas d'accord alors
que ce sera plus des 4 mai noyer pension
dans votre projet on a compris d'accord
mais qui sera moindre et qui de toute
façon on permettra ce que les candides
et une augmentation significative des
retraites actuellement il ya une décote
ce qui est absolument scandaleux et
qu'il faut pénaliser vous l'avait
chiffré cette réforme oui on off tout ça
sur notre site on lan a fait campagne là
dessus mais bien sûr de façon là vous
voulez se changer de sujet mais c'est à
dire je dis non non non non mais pardon
est ce que c'est que pendant là où vous
vous trouvez c'est qu'on a l'impression
comme quand on joue quand on écoute ce
serait un recul social alors que c'est
une formidable avancée après on peut
discuter et nous si on est en
responsabilité sans aucun doute qu'on
continuera à améliorer compris pourquoi
pas prendre en compte la période de
formation dans sa durée dans ce durée de
travail et ces termes ne pas travailler
sur tous ces dossiers
juillet d'ores et déjà ça voudrait dire
que des millions de gens pourront partir
plus tôt à la retraite avec des
ronds les conditions qu'il n'y aura pas
de retrait
vous serez clair sur le fait que la
personne qui commence à travailler à 25
ans et qui donc partir avec votre
système à 65 ans il perdra pas d'argent
est ce que ce sera clair est-ce parce
que pour l'instant que vous ne me dit
pas quel sera le montant de la pension
c'est une parlez-lui décote mais une
blague j'espère pardon mais c'est une
plaisanterie actuellement des gens selon
les carrières vache si vous voulez je
peux faire un simulateur de retraite et
tout va prendre chaque saison je vous
informe que la pension qu'on reçoit
dépend aussi de ce que vous avez cotisé
de voeux de vos revenus mais tout le
monde sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
quand vous allez voir quelqu'un sur
votre tête vous trouver non seulement
par pour nombre de trimestre comme que
vous avez que vous avez cotisé mais
aussi je le répète si vous voulez partir
plus tôt vous vous retrouvez avec cette
terrible décote donc c'est à l'heure
actuelle le centaines de monsieur m'a
comprends pas vous indigner et tellement
analysant mais on chauffe à améliorer
les choses et vous voulez me faire dire
qu'en gros il va là
on essaie de
c très bien ça a toujours été comme ça
d'ailleurs même qu'à l'époque vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure on a parlé
bien sûr de l'europe aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui s'est dit
favorable à une révision des traités
ursula von der leyen avant lui a dit
soutenir une modification des traités si
nécessaire est ce que ce n'est pas la
preuve qu'on peut changer les traités
sans la désobéissance en désobéir ce qui
est voué à votre position évoquant les
deux seraient contradictoires nous
changeons les si on veut et par ailleurs
un pays aussi peut dire c'est d'ores et
déjà le cas vous savez sur nombre de
sujets je crois que l'allemagne par dix
sept fois a désobéi à des traités
européens notamment il ya eu on l'a vu
même à l'occasion de la triche ducobu
d'une désobéissance générale face à la
situation mais là il ya la possibilité
de changer
il a eu des paroles là dessus mais ça va
donc du coup ça va dans le bon sens pour
vous si ça c'est pas du tout je vais le
prendre positivement c'est la
démonstration qu'à l'heure actuelle même
ceux qui sont les plus grands comment
dire défenseurs de cette union
européenne disent que ça fonctionne plus
très bien et qu'il faudrait voir tout ça
me propose pas du tout la même solution
mais peut-être mais je ne suis pas avec
madame dindar yens ou monsieur macron ce
que je dis moi c'est clair enfin -
pardon de cet hymne modestine ce que
nous disons c'est que si on arrive en
responsabilité la politique que nous
avons mis dans nos programmes nous
l'appliquerons même si ça doit créer des
tensions et des rapports de force au
sein d'europe pour faire bouger les
lignes positive même si ça vous met en
marche de l'europe même si ça va nous
permettre à pension avec le ram et ja je
le répète l'allemagne 17 fois depuis ces
dernières années qui a désobéi à
différentes fins politiques et si on en
fait une politique on se met vraiment
commencé la deuxième puissance le
deuxième pib de l'union européenne nous
feront bouger les lignes parce que de
quoi on parle il s'agit pas de dézoomer
vous mettrez en main à l'europe on
pouvait pas faire plonger au coeur de
l'onu est-ce que vous pouvez nous ont
fait perdre en est ce que mais c'est une
question est ce que vous pouvez faire
bouger les lignes alors que vous mettrez
en contravention avec les règles
européennes oui il est contradictoire
non c'est vous qui le dites et je pense
qu'à l'heure actuelle ce que vous pensez
que la hongrie qui contrevient à
l'européenne et un le leadership sur
l'europe est ce que vous pensez qu'un
pays comme la pologne qui parfois
dénoncé c'est vrai a cru que son mandat
national lui permettait de dire qu'elle
ne respecterait pas et que ces polonais
7 hongrie quelles sont les sanctions
qu'elle a subi soyons sérieux
enfin en même temps à l'heure actuelle
observée de toute manière qui
premièrement il ya une évolution de la
construction l'union européenne sur
lequel les jeux parce qu'ils nous
écoutent en jugeront mais moi je
considère que c'est une l'évolution
libérale de l'europe qui s'est éloigné
de du grand projet de solidarité entre
les peuples qui est essentiellement
marqué je le répète par des traités qui
sont kim est la règle du libre échange
qui sont amenés sont à affaiblir des
services publics qui sont indispensables
sur lequel nous voulons mettre un terme
à cette évolution voilà on veut pas
casser en soit le projet européen mais
dire s'il ya des choses qui doivent
cesser à partir à la stratégie que nous
mettons en place elle est tout à fait
honnête et sincère qui est de dire nous
sommes le 2e pib de l'union européenne
ce que fait la france a des conséquences
les mesures que nous prendrons amènera
nos partenaires d'ailleurs contrairement
à ce que vous dites tout le monde voudra
de sauter à la gorge mènera peut-être à
des nouvelles solidarités parce que les
problèmes que nous pourrons régler c'est
quoi c'est de dire notamment si nous
voulons faire un emprunt si nous voulons
refaire faire de la relance économique
si nous voulons défendre des services
publics et bien si certains traités
européens nous en empêche nous le ferons
quand même et je suis persuadé que ses
préoccupations de défendre des biens
communs de pouvoir avoir des politiques
de relance économique intéresse aussi
d'autres gouvernements tout petit
est ce que c'est une bonne chose de
généraliser le vote à la majorité
qualifiée c'est ce que souhaite emmanuel
macron à ce que l'une est limitée à 27
aujourd'hui c'est devenu trop
contraignant mais façon ce système est
bloqué d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est une bonne chose non je ne le
qualifierais pas de bonne chose parce
que si c'est l'occasion aussi de tordre
le bras aux décisions des différents
gouvernements ça n'est pas une bonne
chose mais vous voyez que ce soit l'une
ou l'autre solution on voit bien la
situation de blocage dans lequel nous
sommes arrivés donc de toute manière il
faut qu'il y ait une redéfinition de ce
que nous voulons faire en europe et un
oui sans doute
[Musique]
dans ce rôle et n mélenchon dommage on
n'ira pas droit mais effectueront moi je
reste convaincu au delà de tous les
aspects techniques que tous les peuples
d'europe constate que nous avons comme
en irak le libre échange qui a des
conséquences écologiques qui ne sont pas
favorables au peuple que nous avons une
impuissance sur la montée des inégalités
que nous avons dans différents pays des
problématiques à laquelle l'union
européenne ne répond pas donc c'est ça
la discussion pendant les choses à bras
le corps ils sont où les vous vous êtes
satisfait par dont vous êtes dans votre
évidemment de journalisme et vous pensez
que les peuples d'europe sont satisfaits
par cette union européenne la vivre
comme un paradis sur terre ça n'est pas
le cas d'autres soyons fiers d'être
français si je peux faire une certaine
manière si on a un gouvernement qui dit
ben voilà nous on va mettre une
politique dont on pense qu'elle va être
un élément de redynamisation de notre
économie de
mettre un terme à ces différentes
inégalités etc et que l'on s'y rendre et
fait alors concrètement si emmanuel
macron à une majorité il souhaite faire
de sa première loi une loi de pouvoir
d'achat il y aura le dégel du point
lundi sur a délaré indexation des
retraites sur l'inflation immédiatement
il y aura le chèque alimentation enfin
voilà deux choses formidables vous allez
la beauté
avoue d'une formidable non mais parce
que je m'amuse quoi c'est à dire
qu'après cinq ans totalement contraire à
ce genre de mesure en ton pouvoir
d'achat augmenter non madame année
ça dépend ça n'est pas ce que les
français pensent ça n'est pas examiné si
vous avez les chiffres vous avez vu
l'inflation deux de ces dernières
semaines qui est absolument terrible
franchement
effet mesure de pouvoir d'achat pourquoi
voulez voter pas parce que premièrement
temps départ dont vous n'êtes pas le
service de communication de l'elysée je
ne sais même pas de quoi vous parlez
vous êtes en train de parler un
parlementaire d'opposition le président
de la république en campagne a fait des
annonces totalement contraire à ce qu'il
a fait il ya cinq ans et vous me toiser
en dix ans et pourquoi vous ne votez pas
parce que je ne sais pas concrètement et
que en général la parole des manuels
macron est marquée par un caractère
fourbe c'est que contrairement à ce
qu'il dit il fait l inverse c'est ça je
veux dire fourbe et la wii fournis dans
le sens où c'est toujours marqué par une
volonté de flouer les gens c'est ça que
j'appelle la fourberie
dire les choses c'est pour ça qu'on
s'était amusé avec les amis a parlé de
parole orwellienne comme dans le roman
si tu veux la paix prépare la guerre etc
macron c'est ça si tu veux défendre le
travail affaibli le code du travail si
tu veux le droit de manifester restreint
les libertés publiques si tu veux
défendre l'art 65 ans en avoir c'est
juste de l'argent distribué mais vous
savez ce truc pas vous le voyez bien que
vu le contexte d'inflation qui
proposé à l'assemblée nationale une
mesure de blocage des prix s'y sont
opposés violemment où sont-ils et quelle
différence avec un chèque alimentation
votre blocage des prix à pardon c'est
fondamental sais pas si on a essayé avec
un chèque alimentation les prix de
première nécessité ça revient au même
pour les français chère madame je ne les
crois pas sur parole moi j'ai défendu
pendant plus deux mois vous voyez je
change de sujet parce que c'est un
dossier que j'ai porté les frais
bancaires 7 milliards de frais bank 7
milliard de profits par l'établissement
bancaire qui sont faits sur le dos des
pauvres gens parce que notamment période
de crise on vous fait payer le simple
fait que vous ayez un découvert qu'on
nous envoie m 18 euros par 6 18 euros
par là etc les frais bancaires c'est une
ponction un impôt privé sur le dos des
gens ils m'ont ri au nez en me disant
qu'ils étaient en discussions existent à
sion bancaire et qu'ils allaient régler
le problème ça ne cesse de s'aggraver ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que chaque
fois que nous avons été concret à
l'assemblée nationale en demandant le
blocage des prix en demandant la
suppression des frais bancaires en
demandant l'augmentation des salaires en
demandant le gel du point d'indicé ils
ont toujours voté contre et maintenant
comme par hasard en pleine période
électorale
mais moi je voterai tout ce qui améliore
les conditions de vie des gens madame
boucher tout ce qui est meilleur mais
moi jamais je ne suis pas là pour
embêter les gens moi vous savez mon père
est un petit employé d'une mère ne
travaillait pas et tout ce qui améliore
la condition de vie des miens de ceux de
ma famille de mes proches je le vote dès
demain d'accord d'accord maintenant la
réalité ce que je vous dise pourquoi je
vous parle avec verve c'est que les
mêmes qui ont là qu'ils sont persuadés
qu'ils font le bonheur sur terre depuis
cinq ans qu'ils vont encore plus
continuer à le faire concrètement quand
j'analyse les textes qui nous ont
proposé ce n'est pas ça qui a eu lieu
tout de même la loi travail qui
affaiblissait le code du travail qui
facilite les licenciements qui supprime
qui supprime les chsct cessa
concrètement la loi pénicaud qui nous
ont présenté comme une amélioration des
conditions de travail celle inverse qui
a eu lieu le gel du point d'indicé
voyait dans quelle situation est née
nous enseignants qui sont les plus mal
payés d'europe il ne cesse de dire
qu'ils veulent améliorer les conditions
des enseignants j'ai même fait ici en
des bains jour avec une députée remarche
qui m'avait expliqué qu'ils sont
améliorées et qui ne sont mieux payés
ils vivent dans
réalité non une question
institutionnelle sûrement votre projet
votre projet de vième république
est ce que dans votre projet de vième
république il y a un premier ministre
c'est un ski sur wii c'est d'abord la
méthode est importante c'est à dire que
si jean les plongeurs avaient été prises
on a vu que c'est plus compliqué s'il ne
l'est pas mais nous aurions enclencher
un peu ce sont des politiques situations
débat un vote sur des députés
constituants d'une discussion
démocratique sur quelles sont les
nouvelles institutions
dans ce cadre là ce que moi j'aurais
défendu avec mes amis c'est un système
plus parlementaire évidemment dans
lequel en vérité c'est plus un président
du conseil un prémice trappe le comme
vous voulez qui dirige le gouvernement
je goûte peu le fait qu'on soit
aujourd'hui un système d'ultra
présidentialisation qui amène j'ai déjà
donné la formule tout à l'heure une
forme de monarchie présidentielle jeudi
le mot à la fois pour piquer et s'est
pas totalement faux parce que même le
général de gaulle à l'époque avait dit
qu'on était en gros à la synthèse la
5ème république entre les traditions
républicaines et l'histoire des
monarchies et même le emmanuel macron
avait dit rappelez-vous dans une revue
le 1 en 2016 c'est loin il avait dit il
ya un grand vide dans la vie politique
depuis plus de trois ans mais il faut le
combler bref tout ça moi qui suis un
républicain je n'y crois pas pour moi ça
c'est du bonapartisme je n'ai pas besoin
d'un grand homme ou une grande femme je
ne suis pas un enfant je suis un citoyen
et je suis pour que ce soit 577 députés
où on peut discuter dès lors du chiffre
qui discutent au nom du peuple français
avec des droits nouveaux d'ailleurs pour
les citoyens de les contrôler et
éventuellement de les révoquer mecque
des intervenants d'initiative citoyenne
c'est ça mon modèle merci plus démocrate
depuis toujours très pugnace dans un
instant sophie trafic
les réserves de questions et de
pugnacité une question puisque justement
enregistrant parlais tout à l'heure
manuel macron a dit tout à l'heure en
répondant à une question d'une
journaliste à strasbourg qu'il avait
choisi son premier niveau il prend son
temps pour l'annoncer
c'est un stratège qui a bien content
quel objectif parce qu'il valence au
meilleur moment pour lui sans doute cuiv
annoncé en même temps que son premier
ministre quelques nouvelles c'est c'est
comme les pochettes surprises quand on
était petits on va sans doute avoir un
gouvernement avec telle ou telle
personnalité qui va faire parler
peut-être telle ou telle prise dans une
c'est trop quelle famille politique et
je crois c'est un peu l'analyse que j'ai
là il y avait des vacances nous on a mis
en place notre nouvelle union populaire
vous en avez beaucoup parlé le président
us dire c'est un peu leur moment je les
laisse faire et puis sans doute qu'il va
chercher à reprendre la main dans un
agenda médiatique pour donner à voir
précisant la discussion qu'on avait avec
vos deux confrères tout à l'heure que
c'est merveilleux que ces deux nouveaux
juges oublie le vocabulaire qu'il a eu
pour son investiture en gros on rentre
dans une nouvelle période ou si vous
êtes nouveau quinquennat si vous étiez
pas content des cinq ans précédents
rassurez-vous les cinq ans qui viennent
doit être formidable mais il faut à
nouveau c'est un stratège je veux dire
cet homme je ne critique pas je salue
sur d'intelligence tactique politique
non mais attendez l'homme a peut-être
des efforts mais je lui reconnais que
c'est un chef de guerre politique
j'entends évidemment tout à fait
respectable mais permettez que nous
aussi nous ayons pas ses ambitions
bonjour alexis merci j'ai entendu des
tas de choses tout à fait passionnante
et qui volait très haut des grands
sujets régaliens je vais redescendre un
tout petit peu dans la cuisine ne se
veut pas madame dans les hauteurs on va
essayer dans les cuisines de la nuque ps
ou de la nuque je ne sais pas exactement
quelle est la façon à la nouvelle union
populaire voilà la nouvelle union
populaire mais avec les soucis
socialiste sur écologique et sociale
absolument je suis un peu surprise de
voir les premiers accrocs qui lie alors
évidemment on s'y attendait mais
notamment avec fabien roussel donc à la
tête du parti communiste ce matin qui a
jugé que la candidature de ta aboaf dans
la 14e circonscription du rhône à
vénissieux était une candidature
inacceptable est-ce que ça devient un
point de rupture cette candidature cette
personnalité de ta aboaf comment est ce
que vous le jugez vous alors vous
connais sophie de ravinel et j'aimerais
vraiment je moi aussi je vous connais
non mais je le dire je j'ai de respect
pour vous c'est ça que je veux dire et
puis jouent parfois j'ai tendance à moi
même à mettre aux deux passions dourdan
les choses bon moi je pense qu'on vit un
grand moment dans ce que nous sommes en
train de faire je forme le voeu que nous
gagnons et j'aimerais que tous ne se
ramène pas à des sujets qui sont à je
vous ai prévenu que j'allais voir
attendez donc tout à l'heure j'ai donné
le chiffre à vos deux confrères shopian
1500 candidats qui se sentirait il est
possible que dans 10 cas répondre ah
oui pardon il est possible que dans dix
quinze vingt endroits ça frotte un peu
parce que l'effort cas là n'en attendais
pas mais c'est possible mais d'abord le
général c'est que ça se passe bien c'est
que globalement mais jamais jamais
jamais ce jeu mais déjà c'est un parti
pris oui vous prenez choix j'assume
c'est un parti pris a pas d'accord donc
tout va bien la nouvelle union populaire
est en dynamique dans les
circonscriptions ça se passe bien
d'accord donc vous faites un choix est
un choix partisan éditorial comme
je sais pas ce que c'est parce que
manuel maquereau ou ça lui même jugé que
la candidature et j'y reviens figaro qui
a décerné même élan à la deuxième manche
j'affirme ici qui a plus de problèmes au
sein de la république en marche mais ça
je trouve que moi qui suis allé regarder
la télé
mais dont cap non mais c'est une manière
de vous répondre
parce qu'ottawa pff je me suis déjà
exprimé à son sujet table je me suis
déjà exprimé à son sujet c'est bon il ya
577 candidats mais
reprend la déclaration c'est ce que
je vais bien ne t'en fais remet pas dans
le rôle quel que soit ce que tu penses
de vouloir uniquement comme mounir el
rey a exacerbé des petits problèmes et
par ailleurs ne profite pas des médias
et c'est vrai ça va bien ou celle pour
éventuellement avoir une discrimination
table du valais en vue d'avoir une
rupture là dedans avec une ressource pas
de toute manière il ne le faut pas si
possible ne faut pas que de toute
manière les dans les 577
circonscriptions les problèmes plus ou
moins importants soient des motifs à
carreaux à sa candidature qui est assez
provocante pour beaucoup est-ce que vous
ne jugez pas que est ce que le jeu en
vaut vraiment la chandelle pour une
candidature qui vaut autant la table
finale je vois position cette année
c'est une icône des cycles est une icône
personne ne tirant pas ça moi même et si
je laissais ma place pour arranger les
choses je la laisserai c'est pas le
sujet non pas le sujet dans doute mais
non mais je veux dire si le doute est ce
que vous voulez quoi mais je veux dire
soyons une vie ayons une vision d'abord
le général et après le particulier rien
ne doit faire obstacle à cette union la
notamment je m'adresse à mon camarade
fabien il a le droit et c'est tout à
fait respectable et le parti communiste
est un grand parti de considérer que les
choses auraient pu être différents mais
nous avons réussi à créer des conditions
que cette union donc j'aimerais que
personne ne s'enferment dans le rôle du
tonton ronchon au bout de la table qui
passe son temps à dire qu'il ya tel ou
tel problème je n'ai que chaque
graphique des jeux termine
stratégiquement je demande à tous ceux
qui ont l'honneur de venir cerveau
plateau quand vous nous faites l'honneur
aussi et la gentillesse de nous inviter
de profiter de l'occasion pour diffuser
de la bonne humeur et de la volonté de
gagner voilà pourquoi là dessus j'ai un
désaccord avec fabien vous l'avez bien
compris de dire attention ne passons pas
notre temps et
pour que l'âme attendait par ailleurs
c'est pas un tel ou tel de décider qui
doit être candidat bon sens et aussi un
peu c'est une discussion c'est un accord
comme allumer d'accord mais c'est aussi
la france insoumise qui décidera de tel
ou tel candidat bon sens justement était
réversible
si l'on soit c'est pas le sujet mais si
c'est le sujet qui oppose non l'annoncé
c'est pas une manière mais attendez ce
qu'on aime mais ça peut les gelées dit
je les dis et je vous réponds
politiquement prenez le j'espère que ne
pas me manquer de respect je ne suis pas
là je vous dis vous parce que ça m'est
arrivé à d'autres émissions pour qu'un
jour ils me disent vous devez virer
untel ou untel nous nous déciderons de
ce que nous ferons
non mais parce que
le sujet revue en permanence l'actualité
de fait voter par un nouveau partenaire
qui a signé une accords historiques
avaient alors j'ai profité de l'argent
vous voulez c'est à dire les questions
voulait choisir
choisi par les avis mais c'est beaucoup
un pardon allant des soyeux n'entendez
continent mais attendez je ne choisis
pas je réponds mais je répond d'une
manière qu'on aura compris qui est qu'
on est à quatre semaines d'une élection
est en train de dire aux uns et aux
autres les amis s'il ya des problèmes à
régler entre nous ne profitons pas des
médias parce que ça ne sert à rien voilà
ce que je en train de dire et je dis à
tout le monde quel que soit ce que pense
olivier faure julien bayou mon ami
manuel bompard ou machin n'utilisons pas
ces médias parlent ont écouté ce qui
nous regarde et je veux augmenter le
smic je vais leur dette à 60 c'est à
nous ne perdons pardon ça que je suis je
suis désolé je peux je continue à perdre
reconnaissez que il y a des soucis qui a
des points de friction et des points
forts et notamment à côté
sinon martineau cette socialiste qui
pose la question à jean luc mélenchon et
là aussi je vous la pose le message de
mélenchon est ce que c'est mon gendre
avant les femmes parce que à la place où
elle devait aller il y a donc son gendre
gabriel amard qui est parti en essonne
qui est parti dans les hauts de france
qui est partie non c'est une question et
qui a atterri là après avoir été dans
chaque élection 2012 2017 2020 t1 2020
aussi d'ailleurs à correct c'est pas
comme quoi c'est pas correct parce que
pose est ce que
remarque rien d'embarrassant mais
peut-être que cette dame tout à fait
respectable
très bien qui est une militante
socialiste tout à fait respectable
aurait préféré fléchirait souhaité être
candidate ce qui est tout à fait
respectable d'accord est déçu ce qui est
tout à fait respectable que ce soit une
circonscription france insoumise
deuxièmement nous dans nos rangs tout le
monde a les jambes on a à coeur j'en ai
je vais venir à cet aspect on a à coeur
de veiller à ce que partout y est la
parité qui est des femmes qui soit
candidate ici c'est peut-être un homme
finalement de tonnerre on le respectera
c'est une question de principe enfin un
mot sur verrier la marque c'est là où
vous en veux si je me permets de dire
que c'est le gendre de jean luc
mélenchon est alors d'accord cet homme
fait de la politique depuis l'âge de 19
ans il a 35 ans d'engagement politique
il a été maire il a été maire il a été
maire de viry châtillon tout un monde à
conseiller général vice président du
conseil général le plus jeune maire de
france c'est un an c'est un homme qui a
rédigé nombreux ouvrages notamment pour
faire de l'eau un bien pu ainsi ce
dimanche
weise dirigeante poggio this it l'avez
vous dire les choses c'est un dirigeant
politique et c'est un homme qui a été
mon dirigeants politiques qui m'a formé
sur nombre de sujets dire de gabriel
amard aujourd'hui conseiller régional de
cette région tient de la famille depuis
plus d'un siècle à villeurbanne et qui
connaît parfaitement don lever avant
l'arrivée la vie régionale et sefyu
d'amener à la marde dirigeant historique
d'aller cette figure du département les
son prénom mais
elle ne songe pas du tout fait sa
carrière dans cet endroit là il est allé
dans les endroits différents c'est quand
il est allé dans le jura il est allé
dans le nord de l'essonne vous l'avait
dit lui même il est arrivé là c'est un
dirigeant politique b2 pourquoi pas ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est quand
même plan la critique bassam a pas
échappé ça m'a pas échappé vous dites
aujourd'hui le fait qu'il fasse sa vie
plus que ça d'ailleurs avec la fille de
jean luc mélenchon ne vous autorise pas
je vous dis avec gravité a résumé
gabriel amard le jean de jean luc
mélenchon parce que j'ai bien compris
derrière c'est la principauté de monaco
vous à comprendre un des cas d'accord
sur le fait qu'il y aurait des biens en
reste il est alors moi la personne avec
qui je vis est une dirigeante politique
met d'accord et c'est le cas et on sème
aussi au sein de ce grand mouvement et
il arrive parfois qu'on se sait pas
correctement la vie alors et vous voulez
quoi voulez la carte du tendre de chacun
qui fait quoi et qui sait vous voulez
sauf philosophique et mondes à écouter
moins bien parce que je sais que vous le
connaissez gabriel amard et les
dirigeants politiques un dirigeant
politique et s'y laver l'honneur ce que
je souhaite d'être un député il ferait
un formidable députés est ce que sa vie
privée qu'il aime aujourd'hui n'a rien
avoué savez bien que c'est pas le sujet
et full hd sans danger c'est pas dégeu
fisam ans pourquoi pas qu'elle
sous-entend sophie c'est que le fait que
soit le genre ya longtemps qu'elle est
jalousé par préférence familiale c'est
ce qu'a dit c'était bien leurs élus
liste est bien le sujet l'eau et la
torre sais pas qui s'accompagne en
avance localement comment ça se passe
comment ça se déroule moi ce que je
voudrais des rivalités avec ça c'est sûr
alors j'ai une autre question quand même
qui m'intéresse parce que vous parlez
des femmes vous voyez quelque chose de
positif samedi on a entendu une femme
qui s'appelle rachel kéké qui a été
absolument applaudi et qui a pris qui a
fait un discours très fort samedi donc
lors du grand rassemblement de la nuit
baisse elle a été investie par lé fille
elle a été je le rappelle pour les
auditeurs porte parole des femmes de
chambre de 22 mois de grève dans les
lycées que cette boîte ignore absolument
et c'est une figure une figure de la
lutte sociale qu'est ce que vous lui
avez offert puisqu'elle est aujourd'hui
candidate dans le val de marne qu'est-ce
que vous avez offert comme cette comme
formation à cette personne qui peut
potentiellement être propulsé députés à
l'assemblée en juin prochain est ce que
vous l'avez fort mais qu'est ce que le
mouvement des insoumis lui a proposé lui
a donné si quelqu'un doit fermer celles
qui doivent former vous l'avez écouté
oui je les écoutais absolument mais
j'ose imaginer la bleue si les portes ne
laisse que ça vous est de laisser un
commentaire exige une formation ou non
pour son patient se formera sur le temps
moi quand je suis arrivé à l'assemblée
je connaissais rien je sais pas
d'ailleurs si aujourd'hui si je sais pas
moi qui les communistes et les
socialistes d'ailleurs et vous l'assumez
ça vous dit que les parlementaires les
futurs parlementaires n'ont pas besoin
d'être formés au travail parlementaire à
ce qu'ils se forment cette année c'est
des citoyens l'honneur de la politique
c'est quand les polices la politique est
aussi un lieu de formation et des
nations l'honneur d'un grand mouvement
c'est quand quelqu'un qui est par
ailleurs c'est un métier tout à fait
honorable une femme de chambre qui n'a
sans doute rachel n'a sans doute pas de
diplôme qui est une femme courageuse qui
s'est battu pour éviter ce soir et ça va
sans doute être très heureux de sa
présence les aléas pas que françois mais
je veux dire écoutez je ne sais pas si
on gagnera je le souhaite mais s'il ya
des rachel qui rentre à l'assemblée
nationale pour faire entendre la voix de
ces gens payés comme on irait
extrêmement mal méprisé par une
direction qui pendant des mois leur a
refusé tout simplement des conditions de
travail élémentaire et bien il y aura
rien de plus beau est cantonné
républicain pas de formation donc mais
parce que racheter qui participera à sa
force du pardon je ne comprends pas bien
le sens de la question parce que
regarder une anne sophie pelletier qui
est député européen qui elle même avait
été une héroïne des luttes sociales
les ehpad du jura etc elle s'est
complètement effondrée elle le reconnaît
l'annulation a été formé elle accuse le
mouvement interne de ne pas l'avoir
formé de ne pas l'avoir soutenu fait est
ce qu'il y à des chutes comme ça et ce à
travers banny est ce que vous ne
reconnaissez pas qu'ils auraient besoin
au sein du mouvement des insoumis d'un
institut de formation de quelque chose
qui ne lâche pas dans la nature mais
passer par une formation mais là où je
m'étonne c'est paul citer des cas de
alors les aides soignantes et mais alors
vous savez il ya des gens extrêmement
diplômés qui à l'assemblée nationale ce
libraire mais absolument mais que voulez
des noms mais jamais dépouilles sont
jamais là où je veux dire et ils sont
sûrs bardé de diplômes au liban il
présente bien ils ont même des costumes
et des cravates mais il va le payer à
chevilly d'une permutation d'accord donc
rachel cliquer elle aura sans doute
parfois vocabulaire comment dirais-je
qui sera plus brut que ce qu'on a
entendu jusque là mais ce qu'elle fera
entendre dans cette maison du peuple
parce que vous aimez en partage l'idée
que l'assemblée nationale doit être la
maison du peuple si elle fait vibrer les
colonnes un peu au delà du palais
bourbon en faisant entendre la voix de
ces femmes qui étaient mes
questions dernière ils ont très rapide
est-ce que vous souhaitez à terme via
d'ailleurs ce groupe qui va se former un
bain via la nuque est-ce que vous faire
vous souhaitez la formation d'un groupe
unique d'un parti unique à gauche est ce
que c'est quelque chose dont vous rêvez
excellente question à ce stade nous ce
qu'on a dit c'est que chacun aurait
droit au ras les conditions d'un groupe
parlementaire nous voulons qu'au sein de
l'assemblée nationale ya un intergroupe
ça fonctionne ils sont a priori tous
d'accord alors il faut le faire vivre
et deuxièmement ce qu'on a souhaité
aussi c'était ce parlement l'union
populaire qui soit aussi un lieu de
régulation politique parce que nous on
souhaite que ce dont on a discuté
continue d'être débattue et que comme
que tout soit pas ramené d'ailleurs à la
vie parlementaire oui il ya unique non
venons d'abord un lieu dans lequel on a
besoin unique un peu comme le ferait une
fédération le pas avec une édition
direct
je pense que vous en rêvez on n'en est
pas là mais je vais vous dire c'est
comme le vélo tout ça si ça avance ça
tiendra droit mais vous le souhaitez moi
j'aimerais bien qu'au bout d'un moment
on arrive à faire en grand boubou là je
parle en mon nom mais bien parce qu'il
ya une grande formation populaire dans
lequel nick y compris les rachel kéké de
ce pays rentrent en masse pour dire bon
sens jugé c'est là que ça se passe et si
on arrive à moi je pense que ce que j'ai
constaté c'est peut-être notre
conclusion c'est que à l'occasion du
débat qu'on a eu c'est qu'il y avait des
clients votre conclusion parfois était
artificiel en raison de l'existence
d'appareils politiques et dès qu'on
parle politique parfois on s'aperçoit je
reprends mots de jean luc que les
caricature des dents et des autres ne
sont finalement pas tout à fait juste
sans doute que certains nous ont
caricaturé et peut-être que nous mêmes
on a caricaturé parfois nos amis
écologistes nos amis socialistes et
quand on discute du fonds on arrive à
faire des choses ensemble merci beaucoup
il avait compris que c'était votre
mouvement unique c'est intéressant non à
l'aide pour avoir une perspective vous
voulez faire oui mais on est d'accord
attendez que je n'ai pas la personne que
ce donc que nous avons écrit c'est que
chaque formation à son groupe et
personne n'est t'amener tous qu en
reparler ça veut dire que vous savez
jamais mesures chacun de mal parce qu'on
va de merde
merci alexis corbière d'avoir été avec
nos auditions publiques bonne campagne à
vous et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bien sûr pour audition
publique à la même heure 19h30 sur
public sénat et la chaîne parlementaire
bonne semaine
[Musique]